Russia has tried to put Ukraine Under
Siege
but thanks to Europe's solidarity Lanes
Ukraine has kept trading with the world
solidarity Lanes have brought Ukraine's
food to the world and vital revenues
into the country
and they have proven to be an
indispensable Lifeline that works
regardless of Russia's recurring threats
against Maritime shipping
and this is why today the European
commission is investing an additional
250 million euros
to boost our solidarity Lanes
millions of people in the world's most
fragile countries rely on Ukraine's
crops for their survival
Russia intentionally
try to starve them
in blockading Ukrainian ports
preventing ships full of grain from
reaching the world
and by doing so millions of people and
fragile countries from Somalia to Yemen
are put on the brink of starvation
we Europeans will not let that happen
we created emergency corridors to bring
weed Maize and oil seeds out of Ukraine
to Global Food Markets
thanks to our solidarity leads Ukraine
has exported more than 15 million tons
of agricultural Goods
this is roughly 60 percent
of all Ukrainian food exports since the
war started
together with a U.N brokerage deal to
reopen Black Sea ports
our solidarity Lanes have stabilized
Global food prices
and brought immediate relief to
countries in need
solidarity lanes are the most reliable
way for Ukraine to trade with Europe and
the world
they have brought more than 15 billion
euros of much needed revenues to
Ukrainian farmers and businesses
and they contribute to a closer
integration of Ukraine's economy with
the European Union
where Russia's so destruction
Europe restored hope
but solidarity lanes are now reaching
that capacity limits and need urgent
Investments Ukrainian Railways and Roads
need repair
waiting times at border crossings must
be reduced
border countries including Moldova that
have become Ukraine's gateway to the
world need more support
and this is why we will boost the
solidarity Lanes with 250 million euros
of additional investment in the short
term
and of course we will further improve
connections between Ukraine Moldova and
the rest of Europe in the medium term
the solidarity lanes are a powerful
example of how we can stand up to the
aggressor through creativity
decisive action
solidarity and cooperation
for the good of Ukraine and the whole
world